zigaretten
wo sind wir denn hier gelangen die leute
hey leute was geht ab und damit herzlich
willkommen das war nur ein video ich
hoffe natürlich jedes gut ich hatte
diesen rucksack bei mir in der wohnung
wo wir gerade sind deswegen startet das
video von hier weil ich den weiter
verschenken möchte und irgendwie habe
ich den letzten mitgenommen auf jeden
fall ich hoffe ihr habt also das letzte
video gesehen da haben wir ja bereits
zwei koffer ausgepackt ich hatte
irgendwie auch alle auspacken können
aber habe ich nicht gemacht habe ich
doch ehrlicherweise und zwar in teilen
kann tut mir leid aber wenn ihr das
erste video noch nicht gesehen habt
check das unbedingt unbedingt akkus zur
erklärung für die die es noch nicht
gesehen haben wir haben wieder einige
neue koffer erstarken unter anderem auch
diesen kinder rucksack mit dem wir jetzt
halt starten und ich würde sagen
deswegen da manchmal gar nicht lange
machen ihn gleich mal auf und mal
schauen was da so drin ist bezahlt habe
ich für den 34 euro plus versand also so
um die 40 euro wirklich 40 euro für
diesen fucking rucksack das muss man
sich mal geben ach was dieses hündchen
sagt mir noch was dann habe ich immer
auf dem ds gespielt nds sehr gut der
rucksack kostet immerhin schon mal 20
euro jetzt brauchen wir noch fünf
brotdosen da drin und dann haben wir ja
die 40 euro vielleicht wieder raus ich
hoffe das video wird trotzdem cool und
lustig für euch manchmal ist es
natürlich dann vielleicht doch ein
bisschen langweilig weil in den koffern
leider nur schrott und das ich habe
immer gehofft das was geiles drin ist
oder irgendwie mal was neues aber es
sind immer so alte klamotten die kein
schwein kennt wirklich da frage ich mich
wie kann das sein dass in dem koffer
nicht mal einen adidas t shirt drin ist
nun mike polley vielleicht auch meine
jacke oder sonst was also nur so marken
drin von denen habe ich noch nie nie nie
etwas gehört und das finde ich halt ein
bisschen komisch dann haben wir auch
hier und da mal eine ray ban dabei und
immer irgendwelche abgefragten kopfhörer
die wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
funktionieren keine ahnung wir haben
heute ja auch noch koffer vielleicht ist
heute anders aber ich starte jetzt
erstmal mit dem kinderbuch sack und da
bin ich wirklich mal gespannt hier haben
wir als erstes grass okay das
funktioniert ja nicht mal ich weiß zwar
nicht was mit den kindergarten nimmt
aber gut weitergeht mit einem auto ist
ein hühnchen drin noch also das ist
schon wieder genau das nächste beispiel
ich musste gleich noch mal was zu sagen
weil ich finde das so haben wir das
nächste stofftier in dem rucksack noch
eine tasche dann haben wir hier ein buch
also gut man muss sagen es ist viel drin
der flughafen buch ja zigaretten
karten ja natürlich welches kind geht ja
nicht im kindergarten jürgens kommt wir
spielen jetzt erst mal eine runde skat
also es ist halt kein rucksack na das
ist ja ganz klar es ist einfach stumpf
es ist für mich super schade hier das
nächste buch ihre gegenwart zum ausmalen
dann haben wir hier noch so ein
transformer ding so kann man raus auch
und noch mehr stifter zwei neue karten
sets also ich muss ja wirklich sagen
wenn man zum beispiel als vater so was
für sein kind ersteigern und es dem kind
schenkt würde ich sagen ist ja mega
kleines geschenk da freut sich jedes
kind rüber auf 48 euro diese ganzen
sachen da kann man absolut nicht meckern
im vergleich zu dem kopf hat ist das
viel besser als ich hab mir den kopf ja
immer so um die 100 bezahlt nur es ist
ja eine fundsachen auktion und da wird
dann ein kinder rucksack circa zwei
kilogramm im koffer circa sieben
kilogramm versteigert und das ist ja
offensichtlich so dass der mit den
sachen mit denen er irgendwo gefunden
wurde versteigert wird und als wenn
dieser rucksack so aussage ich meine wer
nimmt denn zwölf verschiedene
spielsachen in seinem rucksack mit also
das macht ja gar keinen sinn oder muss
ja auch irgendwo anders dann sein was
man wirklich braucht tagtäglich wisst
ihr was ich meine also auch bei den
koffern auf mich wirkt es nicht so als
wären das halt alles riehle koffer wie
sie wirklich mal gefunden wurden klar
bargeld smartphones werden rausgenommen
aber trotzdem ist es halt irgendwie
selber zusammengestellt ist halt schade
und deswegen habe ich schon gesagt im
letzten paar leute ich brauche irgendwie
mal unkontrollierte waren dass wir
einfach geil ich falls ins büro da haben
wir noch koffer und ich bin mal gespannt
was da an und ist leute ich glaube das
hier ist kein normaler koffer ich habe
nämlich hast wo von meinem koffer
experiment erzählt und die meinten alex
wir schicken die auch ein koffer zu und
ich gehe mal davon aus dass sollte der
hier sein das geile ist klar ich werde
davon sicherlich auch was balten aber
das meiste was hier drin ist und da
vorne ist noch ein großes paket das darf
ich wieder an euch verlosen es kann
alles mögliche sein von lastern
anlässlich der aktuellen andy bell 2021
die jetzt schon vorbei ist also ihr
könnt die final matches schon abchecken
bis hin zu irgendwelchen
gesellschaftsspielen bin mal gespannt
hahaha man muss halt sagen so ein koffer
ist nicht unbedingt dafür gemacht die
fetten erblasste einzupacken weil er
einfach ein bisschen kleiner sie haben
jetzt aber einmal ghostbusters okay das
ist glaube ich eher für jüngere so sage
ich auch mal aus dann haben wir hier
kabler das hat mir gar nix der explosive
spielspaß das rasante spiel für
schnelldenker und quasselstrippen genau
das falsche für mich obwohl
quasselstrippe passt ja irgendwie und
hier haben wir noch monopoly falsche
spiel findet das falschgeld und werde
reich das legen wir auch mal hierzu und
hier haben wir dann netterweise auch mal
in diesem fach was
die kenne ich noch gar nicht die hatten
wir bei der nbbl niveau blogs mm2 sharks
im test sich mal der sieht ja ganz wild
aus ach jetzt sehe ich das erst werden
wir hier eine flosse
sahen
das lustig jetzt leute da und ist von
restaurant aber die haben gerade keine
gesten ich muss jetzt ja wenigstens mal
gucken wie weit die kommt seit der
rallye
also bei der nbbl hatten wir auf jeden
fall blast ich noch weiter gefeiert
haben aber leute psycho die lampe dieses
paket hat mir hast du auch noch
zugeschickt einfach geil das passt ja
auch super zur weihnachtszeit da hatten
auch im letzten jahr schon einige laster
nicht herausfahren konnte ich haben wir
es noch mal welche zweimal denn hier ist
ja riesig
den kenne ich auch noch nicht junge wird
elite 2.0 flip shots flip 32 bevor ihr
jetzt die final games von der nbbl
abcheck schreibt einfach hunderten
kommentar was ihr davon haben wollt ich
suche mir dann immer ein kommentar aus
schreibt gerne instagram dazu und dann
schicke ich euch das zu die zuschauer
von euch die letzten laufs bekommen
haben den hab ich gestern geschrieben
und jetzt trägt super gerne mal die nba
und dann packen wir natürlich den
nächsten koffer aus stichhaltig möglich
machen was rein theoretisch auch noch
möglich ist drei sekunden noch und die
letzten besser werden
[Musik]
die haben ordentlich was weg gebechert
neuer koffer neues blut in ihr habe ich
gekauft für 105 euro kopf nochmal
3413 okay ich hoffe mal das wird gut
komme ich dritten mal zu euch es ist ein
damen koffer also wir haben hier oben
drauf irgendwie so einen gelben sack
mitunter ist das unterwäsche und ja hier
ist ja ganz ganz viel eingepackt noch
leider ist hier nicht zu ändern das ist
doof und hier ich denke mal kurz einmal
hier die fächer ab jetzt nicht so ein
super untypisch was ich aber sagen kann
in der zwischenzeit ich bin mit jemandem
kontakt er mir eventuell einen
ungeöffneten und und durchsuchten koffer
zur verfügung stellen kann ich hoffe das
klappt wollte ich einfach schon mal
sagen ich starte jetzt hier mal mit dem
gelben sack das sind ja alles drin noch
mal also dass hier sieht mir aus wie
eine tischdecke sieht nicht nur so aus
ist glaube ich auch eine tischdecke des
weiteren haben wir dann hier noch ne
tischdecke und werde es gedacht noch
mittelstrecke wurde ich würde sagen wir
lassen uns von den tisch decken nicht
beeinflussen und machen wir weiter mit
nun
muss auch b hat der wtf das ist einfach
zu größe 34 34 welche frau hat 34 jetzt
von euch jemand der 34 hat also
ausgewachsen wenn er ausgewachsen seite
hat man noch nicht mal 34 das ja
megabits ich warte mal ich hab ich noch
andere schülern welche größe ist das
denn also für mich ergibt alles nur
wenig sind diese schuhe sind viel größer
als die la vielleicht gehören die dann
im kind aber ich weiß nicht so ganz also
irgendwie komisch dann haben wir warten
mal in die nächste tischdecke und jetzt
haltet euch fest wir haben hier wirklich
nur noch unterwäsche also sieht
zumindest so aus dem schönen bh war okay
das jetzt wird es wirklich ein bisschen
eklig also was ist denn da unten aha
also hier haben wir dann im bh schon
wieder china marke dasteht irgendwas auf
die lese strand heißt nicht als wenn die
koffer als also wirklich als würden
diese koffer alle aus china kommen dass
hier ist der nächste bh auch wieder mit
chinesischer aufschrift okay das ist
wieder pervers wenn ich das jetzt
wirklich wenn ich das also was ich
gemacht habe dass da muss man ja
wirklich jetzt aufpassen was man hier
macht und was man besser lies weiter
geht's anna xxl high fashion hier muss
ich sagen das finde ich es eigentlich
neiße sticks xl bisschen over size das
probiere ich doch mal schnell an gebt
euch mal das erste ps was ich jemals in
dem koffer hatte wo ich mir denke das
kann man selber backen und das verrückte
ist es gehört anscheinend einer frau
aber guck mal hier somit diesen akzenten
hier drauf ist doch eigentlich ganz okay
gut vom schnitt her ich weiß ich so ganz
schreibt gerne eure meinung in die
kommentare ich lass das jetzt einfach
mal an ihr haben wir noch einen job hat
ist nicht so besonders eine sonnenbrille
wie lege ich mal hier neben ihr haben
wir auch noch also das sind alles ja im
röckchen je eine rose hier sondern
blitzer mütze wir raten hut was läuft
was läuft was läuft ja warum nicht ich
kann man auch direkt so auf lassen und
dann hier ja das gleiche nochmal als
zebra muster es wird immer besser dann
haben wir das gleiche nochmal als
anderes glitzer mussten jetzt kann ich
zur corona demo gehen guck mal das glück
hat hier alles voll da und hier kommen
wir dann jetzt zu den letzten sachen das
sind halt dann jetzt wirklich unterhosen
oma unterhosen ich muss aber sagen gut
riechen tut der koffer das ist keine
frage wir dann die nächsten schuhe und
hiervon am k & co amk am po
wahrscheinlich noch ein schlepper also
das war bis jetzt der schlechteste
koffer da war ja gar nix drin was
irgendwie wert hat und dann muss ich
leide auch sagen das war schon die damit
einen körper mir haben alle koffer
ausgepackt und ja ich muss sagen es war
das letzte mal dass ich doch irgendwas
ist da hab ich wollte versuchen ich
hoffe natürlich hatte trotzdem spaß beim
anschauen und bitte bitte lass es klappt
und dass ich auch irgendwann mal ein
koffer bekomme er ungeprüft ist in
deutschland wie das funktioniert die
mussten im ausland er steige aber das
kriegen wir auch irgendwie hin aber
gerne kanal wir sehen uns sonntag wieder
gibt es als video haut rein heute